breaking news here at six the nfl wants
to move the lawsuit involving john
gruden to arbitration and now gruden is
saying no way yeah the very latest
opposition filed friday chris matthews
now joining us live in studio with more
chris yeah thanks guys a 24-page finding
was released this afternoon now we
haven't heard the last of former raiders
coach john gruden's desire to take the
nfl to court of his dismissal of that
dismissal of the case now the law
offices of mcdonald and carano filed the
papers that opposes the motion to
dismiss the earlier filing now the
motion indicating that gruden's claim is
not a made-up conspiracy theory also
saying he's entitled to the benefit of
truth all this stems from an
investigation into the washington
commanders and the shroud of secrecy
surrounding the nfl's investigation
where the only revelation so far has
been the release of john gruden's
homophobic and misogynistic emails
finding the motion saying the nevada
court should draw inferences in gruden's
favor rather than accept the defendant's
efforts to rewrite gruden's pleading
we'll certainly have more on that brian
chris thanks for that candidate